dans cette rue d'isium les maisons
tiennent péniblement debout à l'entrée
de celle-ci un panneau indique foyer
avec trois petits enfants
la jeune famille que nous rencontrons
tente de survivre au milieu des horreurs
de la guerre la maison de Margarita a
été touchée à trois reprises d'abord par
l'explosion d'un char puis par des tirs
d'artillerie
et enfin dit-elle par une bombe à
fragmentation que son fils Nikita âgé de
10 ans a vu tomber du ciel
je ramassais des pierres pour jouer
quand j'ai entendu un sifflement dans le
ciel et j'ai crié quelque chose tombe
courront à la cave
c'était effrayant
c'est le dernier à être descendu dans
l'abri pendant qu'il courait des éclats
d'obus frappaient déjà les fenêtres dieu
merci Nikita l'a entendu sinon les
enfants auraient été réduits en miettes
parce que là où il jouait tout a été
touché
en ce mois d'octobre le jardin est
redevenu un terrain de jeu paisible
il n'y a plus d'explosion maintenant
nous n'avons plus besoin de courir à la
maison pour nous cacher
la famille a survécu plus de 5 mois sous
l'Occupation dans cette ville longtemps
concentrée sur la ligne de front
Margarita nous décrit comment elle
hurlait aux soldat russe de lui donner
des provisions je suis têtu j'ai insisté
donnez-nous à manger les enfants ont
faim j'ai trois enfants puis ils sont
venus nous apporter du ragoût et des
pâtes
des aliments inadaptés pour un
nourrisson son bébé Sofiane avait que
trois mois lorsque la Russie a lancé son
invasion
je l'ai allaité c'est ça qui nous a
sauvé même quand les avions volés
au-dessus de nos têtes j'ai essayé de
rester calme parce que je savais que si
je stressais trop mon lait allait se
tarir et j'avais peur de ne plus pouvoir
la nourrir
à quelques rues une autre famille n'a
pas pu fuir pendant l'Occupation
s'éloigner des ruines maintenant que les
combats ont cessé se fera à contre-cœur
pour la maman de ses deux garçons
nos écoles et nos jardins d'enfants sont
complètement détruits il n'y a pas de
soin médicaux approprié je veux vivre
pas seulement survivre
elle aussi à un bébé Catalina né en mai
en plein milieu de la guerre
quand j'étais à l'hôpital il y avait
tout le temps des coupures d'eau et des
coupures d'électricité
mais les médecins m'ont quand même aidé
à accoucher naturellement et tout s'est
bien passé dieu merci
enceinte de 7 mois et coupée du monde
extérieur à l'arrivée des Russes
Antonina ne pouvait tout simplement pas
fuir
une fois ils ont tambouriné à la porte
de manière agressive et nous ont demandé
qu'est-ce que vous faites ici vous êtes
au courant que c'est la guerre dehors
mon mari a répondu vous voulez qu'on
aille où exactement
elle rêve aujourd'hui de se réfugier en
Allemagne pour offrir un répit à ses
enfants le temps qu'il grandisse loin de
cette guerre pour elle l'espère pouvoir
mieux revenir en suite
et nouvel